[Music]
oh it's clear we're here get used to it
do you want to put your phone in a place
to hide it oh no i need it later john
has his phone and we're here to stay oh
this is the real show folks this is the
break room
our daily show that keeps you updated on
all the nerdy news nerdy news
coming up on the show today we got
madame webb update no uh the thirsty
thespians have got themselves a new
member oh
and we have so so so so so much she-hulk
to talk about here on the break room
live from new rockstars headquarters at
our secret location nowhere near bourbon
california two three eight stop saying
the address live on the air i'm brandon
barrick and joining me today we've got
john costa all the way across the coast
i will dox us on purpose no please don't
dock us john thank you uh next to john
we have the lovely the talented the
effervescent jessica clement oh my god i
didn't even get a taste of that no you
don't deserve it
you always make me look so fat on camera
oh
uh and next to me is the boy i wish i
could be tommy back told how you doing
thomas hey what's up gang it's your
mother tom to maximoff
manifesting you to my bosoms oh i didn't
know tonda maximoff was a lovely jewish
mother yes
how comfortable that i legitimately
thought about standing up and suckling
your oh my gosh stop for the show
remember when everybody was mad they're
like there's already a character named
tommy max muff i'm like i ain't the kid
i'm the mom yeah yeah i'm the mommy he's
the mommy uh and you can be the mommy
too if you send in those super chats we
love to get them we love dorito and we
love to hear what you're saying we're
gonna be talking about she-hulk all day
today so if you got questions about the
show got your own thoughts your own
theory send them in we'll be having lots
of discussions around the show today uh
and having a great old time yeah we are
collecting those super chats we don't
have any special redemption necessarily
for today but uh we will try and get
through as many as we can get through
all of them really read them out really
get it going and if we reach 500 in
super chats by tomorrow we're going to
hulk out on the show
and i want to say this i i didn't tell
you guys this but i want to make it
special i don't like it when you add
stuff in if we get to 650 dollars
which is pretty pie in the sky
i'm gonna go full hulk i'm gonna go full
green body paint from my stick from my
singer to my stinger oh no okay the
doctor said the doctor said if we
painted you green again it could be the
last time oh we're not painting oh you
won't be painting me oh
i'm gonna hold my breath to like oh okay
i'm going to get so seasick you did say
you're going to puke earlier today i do
feel like i might puke
you could puke on the show folks it's
all funny i've got a lot going on in
your super chats to make tommy puke come
on f's in the chat for some puke on
camera no i'm sitting next to who wants
some puke play no no he's gonna do tarps
he's gotta go to camera four while he's
saying that for my fetish
he's gonna do it he's gonna puke uh
that's a deep cut of outside the ring or
oh yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
don't make it do it do it
he never puked and he never made it in
the wwe no well actually he's paralyzed
now because he became draws and then uh
d-lo brown accidentally suplexed him the
wrong way on top of his head
it was an accident
stuff happened
well you know what you know what's not
an accident headline
hey folks madame webb the right met the
madame webb movie had some set photos
reveal a pretty good spider-man easter
egg uh take a look at this folks
that's the daily bureau
oh my goodness i can't wait for madame
webb you know what
someone just said throwing rope in the
chat which is all right all right also
our own new rockstars chat is evidently
uh has clarified that it's called
rainbow play when you're turned on by
puke i hope my mom's not watching this
one anyway uh i'm excited for madame
put some webs in the chat if you're a
madame webster like me put two webs for
sydney sweeney in honor of i'm very
excited for madame webb uh i think it
could be a lot of fun you know they got
the daily bugle trucks wrong they're on
the right it said 2003 which is
inarguably the best year uh that's ever
existed okay i thought it was set in the
90s i made it up
wait so it's not taking i don't know
what it takes but you just like plays in
the olden times i think it's supposed to
be taking place like before the rainy
spider-man movie i mean the rumors of
the plot of it may actually make it
sound kind of cool it's basically like a
terminator story where all these like
female spider
web slingers go back in time to save
baby peter parker we did see like set
photos of like a beyonce album that was
out so i think it's the early 2000s zach
just said webb in the chat yeah give me
a web in the chat he said someone shows
that how to use emojis okay sequoia's in
the chat all right sequoia isn't a chat
for brandon's toxic masculinity
it's toxic baby hey next headline
allison brie hopes to play a marvel
villain dog she's thirsty as hell
she was being interviewed by
comicbook.com and she said quote
marvel's gonna do their thing as they
should i think there's a fantasy deep in
my mind
that one day i would get to play a great
marvel villain but i don't know which
one would that be people fans send me
some ideas so i can start the game you
should do your own work allison
i will say for a thirsty thespian at
least have a goal in sight she probably
saw titanium was like i just did three
seasons of glow yeah why am i not doing
that i could have done that did i see
this is she unfamiliar with like marvel
comics she's just seen the marvel logo
she's like i really like the top left
corner of comic books but i never look
any further than that i don't at all
these events i go to with my fellow
thespians they're all talking about the
cash bags they get from marvel i would
like one of those cats
fan cast a squirrel girl for like a full
day yeah
she probably had a conversation with
mark ruffalo and he just started puking
gold coins and she's like i gotta get on
one of these movies
it was unrelated though uh allison brave
for those people
she's married to dave franco james
franklin i don't want to brag she once
sat down for dinner with me and a group
of friends at la poo belle on uh
franklin oh that's funny she once
stepped on my neck and called me a [ __ ]
oh my god i'm joking
yeah
we don't have time for that story hey we
did ask you breakers in the chat if you
think we'll be seeing jay jonah jameson
and madame webb and 77 percent of you
said yes that makes a lot of sense oh i
hope he just keeps sending emails
i hope he's driving he's learning
why can't we just send this through the
written mail yeah there will be a lot of
great timely jokes in that film that'll
be a lot of fun netflix they'll never
announce it send me more written
correspondence about spider-man gangnam
style do you think they'll get jk
simmons to be jay jonah james no you
don't think so if this is supposed to be
the red eminem if this is supposed to be
able to get russell simmons from def jam
oh my gosh he's missing he is
next headline come find us very much
alive marvel studios rejected she-hulk
writers jessica gals on three different
mcu projects she kept asking kevin
feige dates and he was like no i'm
married we did talk about this a little
yesterday she pitched uh the black widow
movie that was very heavily centered
around she-hulk uh
so this is what gal had to say about her
rejected project she said for me i mean
i was elated because it was a dream job
but also i've been rejected by marvel
three times on previous projects so i
was like guess the fourth time is a
charm it worked persistence is key folks
persuasion is key
uh i to know what the other pictures
were i know i want to read these like
the rejected uh treatments or scripts
that they get i bet they're pretty
interesting come on meet cute hook her
up with allison brie yeah she's got the
projects elsa bree has the can-do
attitude there we go and no knowledge of
the mcu
put her in there put her in there hey
and in case you didn't realize it last
night there was a a post-credits scene a
mid-credit scene i guess we call these
uh for she-hulk and every episode is
gonna have one should we do a spoiler
warning i suppose yeah absolutely oh
yeah oh
yeah we're gonna talk about this you
don't need to put the thing up here
no put it up there you go hey folks
swimming we all watched she-hulk episode
one last night when it came out so we're
going to talk about it today yeah if you
haven't watched it that's fine you can
hit that like button stop watching the
video right now and come back to it
after you've finished the episode go
light a tiki torch and watch nerd riding
what are you talking about why didn't
you say their names
they're going to clip this and they're
going to put on their show with 10 other
boxes of people talking that's fine come
on
so yeah every episode of she-hulk's
gonna have a mid-credit post-credit
scene whatever you want to call it feels
like they did that so don't forget those
yeah for us yeah just for us yeah okay
you know this is us has a post-credits
scene every episode is that true is it
really i've never watched a show the
show with erica
yes is there anything on this earth
come on guys
here's another headline for you
wonderful roomies out there uh chris
evans reacted to having the nicest ass
in the mcu and we've got a photo of it
not the ass this is his reaction also i
thought this was a reaction to him
finding out yeah who put this in the
property i don't know
chris evans reacted to having the nicest
ass in the mcu and then the next clip is
we've got a photo of him reacting to you
you know what maybe you should watch
another channel anyway because we're not
doing our due diligence we're not doing
a dd today put on a hawaiian shirt and
go boogaloo yeah he was reacting to him
having uh
uh left his uh presents uh somewhere in
the 1940s
beyond actually friday if we get if we
get a thousand dollars in super chat i'm
going to baptize a baby friday yeah i
thought you were saying we're going to
move to the average life yeah we're
going to be
i'm going to go
on friday
uh he was actually reacting to uh the
the post-credits scene where it was
revealed that he uh effed um can we
throw that up again we all know can we
throw that photo up do you think he said
what did he say he says laughs he said
laughing face lappy face laughing face
zipper face whoa
talk we're gonna does that mean he's in
the s m was that going to
here's another headline for you folks uh
she all they had to cut down on the cgi
they were gonna have a lot of cgi but
they they had to cut it down uh they
said quote once we got into
pre-production and production itself
once somebody had to sit down and start
figuring out the cost of everything it
was like every week i was told can you
cut some more she-hulk scenes can you
change some more shield scenes to jen
could she be jen in more scenes there
were a lot of things that had to be
changed in the last minute to go from
she-hulk to jen even in post you know we
had to cut a lot of shots by virtue just
because it was she-hulk
that sounds like when i was in charge of
the post-production department in iraq
yeah and we're always kind of well i
always wanted you to see me and
everybody yes and that makes a lot of
sense uh we'd always heard that you know
they cut a lot of hulk out of end game
because of
the need for all the cg and every year
the technology gets a little better a
little more efficient uh but i think so
far has been a good um i think it looks
like a lot of hulk a lot of dual volts
running around jessica gow i guess they
uh gave an interview and said that the
sort of flashback to the car crash and
maybe some of that training stuff was
originally going to be in episode 8
which you know marvel loves to do with
their shows is like that penultimate
episode
um i think it fits really well in this
episode but it's possible that when they
made that change they had to sort of
like rush some vfx for the first episode
that they weren't planning on having to
finish for you know eight weeks from now
or whatever i don't mean to go back to
something that we had already talked
about and moved on from but are we gonna
just erase the fact that thanos had the
best cakes in the mcu by far yeah this
poll in the chat yeah yes concerning two
purple circles in the chat for thanos
thor's butt was also fine as hell well
we did have a poll do you think cap has
the best ass in the mcu super scarlett
johansson you guys are fools 60 said
yeah still thor uh
you know we we've toured with we're
putting out the idea of doing a little
like guess the ass here on the break
room as a mandatory fun one of these
days yeah stick around we'll really rate
the asses yeah but i think you can't
deny what chris
and you know what if you got a computer
in front of you go to ratemyass.com
right now
make sure you spell that correctly uh
yeah
you type it in there yeah uh we also got
the hard team we also got some chat pics
uh from who allison
allison bree should play in the mcu look
at all these purple circles
what's wrong with purple circles i don't
know so at some point grimace's ball
sack i don't know at some point we did a
video and the trolls were giving us
purple circles
all right fine
suggestions allison bree could be red
she-hulk oh yeah uh i wanted to go on
this camera graveyard suggested jean
grey that's not a bad thing wasn't
allison bree heavily rumored to play
she-hulk when they initially announced
the show wasn't she like the fan like
that i don't know i probably would have
gone
i don't know tatiana maslany was cast
and announced and then she was like no
i'm not playing she-hulk leave me alone
oh the person that chad that says i look
like tommy's a lawyer i am
i am tommy's lawyer and by the way guys
these charges ain't sticking teflon tom
in the house uh my client doesn't speak
also i said that i was gonna dress up as
a lawyer for the first day of she-hulk
and i thought we all would kind of do it
but then i realized i should have re i
should have you should have made that
clear to me i mean
we kind of showed this
like this contempt contempt
says
mcu i think the only place i'd want to
see her is like uh uh what's his name
mephisto's son oh uh but playing clearly
we'd swapping okay
i like that and just
yo is he like a cool team
i think it's i think it's like it's not
death stroke but it's something like
that that's a different character yeah
the universe you guys are so wild you
guys today for our break room breakdown
is oh our discussion is our break room
breakdown do we have the asset
we have my graph jessica broke down the
episode
we haven't
this is usually my thing so for today's
break room breakdown jessica thinks
titania has connections to the glkh
let's take a look at that clip
titania is seen busting through the
courtroom played by jamila jamil but i
suspect she was hired to break through
the courtroom so they could see jennifer
walters change to she-hulk like i said
earlier i think it was all orchestrated
by holden holloway who was a shady
[ __ ] man
perfect they bleed my cursing so yeah
essentially i think that titania is just
a plant by the glkh just so it can like
lure out uh jennifer walters version of
she-hulk so they could see she-hulk in
action because when she comes into that
room she's so confused and distraught
she looks around and it's not an i don't
think it was like a bad cinematography
shot director point i think it's just
like actually staged they're playing the
scenes they're playing i just think it
was a little weird how she kind of
busted it and i was like are we supposed
to know what's going on and then they
just fight and it's like yeah can i give
a play-by-play of of yeah what i like
give us the play can we roll the can we
roll the thing uh daschle
titania is seen busting through the
courtroom played by jamal by suspect
i was trying to sneak something in
daschle do we have the the clip from the
episode without sound do we still
without just guitar game i might not
have put that on the card that might be
my fault here's what i think is really
interesting about that scene okay i
can't get over why i'm out of the show
i think it's really interesting about
that scene holden holloway right before
um right before titania breaks in sort
of like does this lean back in his chair
and then he looks over at either
jennifer or
where he suspects titanium might break
in from
um which i thought was fascinating he
sort of like tips his hat i noticed i
noticed like right before she busts in
he goes he like kind of sneezes and he's
like
right now
he said get to it
i guess you could say he's
holding on oh
[Applause]
uh
well if that's your theory and i like
this theory it's a good theory because
that really derails jennifer's career
and puts her in a position where they
can
scoop her up
um and like rockets her to fame but her
friend is the one who can really
convince her to change
well i mean she even says though like um
what does she call it she's like uh
you're your duty your sister or whatever
you have to do it like this woman is
playing jennifer like a fiddle here okay
is it it's more so i think we could be
suspicious of this friend well it's
interesting you say because uh after we
come back from like the flashback or
whatever
jennifer pants the camera and says like
uh nikki knows and now you know and i
don't think she mentions anyone else my
family knows my family knows do we think
uh oh maybe maybe chad is a leak for
that aunt that we don't like jen i think
this friend is obsessed i don't trust
nate
i don't i i think nicki's just gonna die
then i i pitched that i picked up my
predictions i think he's gonna die
oh i'm sorry someone asked what the
redemption is in the chat if you're
joining us late there is no redemption
no there is a redemption okay there is a
resemblance i was going to explain that
no no let's continue this crosstalk we
don't have a flare for theatrics like i
do i just don't like the words there is
no redemption
john do me a favor load in the reject
redemption has a clip and then
dasho can we play the redemption clip uh
oh we don't have that oh okay okay
the redemption has been inside you the
whole time
the redemption is
get your super chats to the top of the
list and if we hit
500
we're all gonna be hulks on the show
tomorrow and if we had 650
i'm going hulk from my circle
to my twerkle
wow
from the mouth to the south
we know the redemptions are very fun and
we know that you guys love them and we
love them too but we really wanted to
talk about this first episode of
she-hulk so throw your shield questions
in the chat we want to focus on your
super chats today more than ever so
we're going to try to knock out as many
as we can at the end
do
uh yeah sorry going back to the
discussion about titania titiana
to tiana if we okay so i like the idea
of thinking that nikki's the bad one in
this and trying to set her up
but it'd be it would be so okay so do
you think it would this is a this is i i
know quite a question do you think it
would even help the story if nicki was a
betrayer uh i think that's that's a hat
on a hat right i think it's a little
much yeah it's all it's a lot but in
this world that is venturing closer to
closer to skrulls a world where the dodc
is up to no good like i don't trust
anybody and you know it's very
convenient that she talks her friend
into hulking out in the courtroom right
there that's what i think is interesting
is like you can't really trust anyone
right now and that's why i don't really
trust hulk because i don't think he's
bruce bannon i don't think that his
intentions are um
let me finish i don't think his
intentions are directly harmful i think
they're indirectly harmful so i think
he's like you don't have what it takes
to do this you don't have one you don't
know what it's like to be me and she's
like i live with this every day right so
he's like setting her up for failure
when it's like no i'm going to succeed
i'm going to do well i do not need you
to keep harping on me well and we do
find out you know his blood is like
useful her blood is useful to him
uh uh in like healing himself and
healing his arm so you're right there
it's a lot he has the gay man he's
pulling like a peter thiel and he's just
harvesting her blood yeah yeah this is
uh the amazing spider-man 2 all over
again
it's interesting because um
her blood heals him and then his blood
can heal a planet in the comics so it's
like what is this is he going to like
steal her blood and then jump on a ship
to sacramento i do like his frustration
though because he did have a lot to deal
with he did but now the two other people
have hulked out like abomination and now
she-hulk they get to like keep full
agency of their mind and they don't have
another personality hidden inside them
uh that guy like gamma radiated that
they have to deal with they just get to
be they can hulk out and still be
totally cognizant and uh uh in charge of
their actions 100 i do see his
frustration there he's a little
frustrated he's worked really hard he
made a binder and she's not even reading
it yeah well he's thumb through it he
didn't need like the first 26 big binder
i know but i mean it's 15. i think
turning into a hulk is a big deal
he said it's 15 years of his entire
evolution of going over so it's like
yeah if it's all of the incredible hulk
all we saw the first avengers every
lullaby that natasha sings to him which
my favorite reaction from jennifer
walters being like why is she seeing a
grown woman singing yeah how does that
work and he's like i don't know
she just goes sun's getting pretty low
big guys to him it was a lullaby and
then she pets his hand i think i got
caught i think it got caught wasn't it
originally music that he was listening
to on his headphones
from the song on the ship oh my god
i think they called it the lullaby that
was with the name they gave it because
it puts the hulk to sleep project
lullaby yeah i'm sure i had project
lullaby they had several meetings about
project lullaby
do we have the assets for project
lullaby
i work really hard on this show
yes he does i love everybody in the chat
that is also agree or will agree mainly
with you because tony is very lonely and
he misses uh or tony bruce is very
lonely and he misses tony stark good and
they can throw some hard explosive hard
hats in the chat for hard work and john
okay
get some hard hats in the chat for some
glasses in the chat for me and john
here's why it's not nikki here's why
it's not oh it's not
uh the show's themes right the show's
themes are all about um women and we saw
the women in the bathroom helping her i
just don't think they're gonna have like
her best friend who's also a woman just
straight up betray her please john tell
me about women yeah let me let me get on
myself
another woman stealing from a man
can we clip that
thank you who are who are um it sucks
also because in this first episode um
not to be a a debbie downer um it is a
lot of things that we did see in the
trailer and then the people that we are
introduced to in the show uh are not
only people we see in the trailer but
people that aren't good people uh nikki
is a good person but dennis is not
clearly dennis
of course you did so dennis is not a
good person and then we get uh holden
holloway right and then we see uh just
little snippets if you guys watch my
breakdown i break down every other
person that shows up to you but we get
snippets of like just the courtroom
people and titania so i'm like who is
out to get her right now
i like that so much of this episode was
in the trailers mainly because yeah
burnt through stuff i've seen in the
trailer that's true that is true now
everything is like
the only thing that's going to be new
going forward is daredevil is daredevil
as a pro and frogman yeah we got we got
a lot a lot more than i'm excited about
uh i was also i loved learning about you
know bruce and tony hanging out
the world's ended half of all the people
are gone and they're hanging out the bar
for a little bit he's having a good time
i bet hulk's getting in the
the the chainsaw room just like hey look
what i could do yeah you know what i
mean just doing this buck
pepper swings by for a visit maybe
that's where morgan kind of comes into
the picture one thing we need to do
another three become one
all right we all need that kind of stuff
happening i really want to know how like
tony's assets are being liquidated
whoa
i said i wasn't going to say one horny
thing
but this guy i mean this is the most
horned up mcu show we've gone so far
return
um i forgot what i was saying um
oh no way we derailed you from a point
by interrupting you i but i do i mean i
i i uh i really
i think they're just doing the trash
it's so cool some weird's happening
outside oh i said oh sorry i was saying
that i really want to see how uh his
assets get liquidated and how this
actually
what happens to his beachfront property
in mexico right does he you know this
land that he owns that he bequeathes and
then
uh yeah or yeah and the all the star
stark industry tools are in there so
it's like if that is written to someone
else you have a bunch of stuff down
there which i think is something to hold
on to because in the future if it does
get all liquidated we still have the
bunker
erica did predict happy hogan would make
a cameo in in this show maybe he comes
in and it's like stop telling me like
isn't he still being sued
right i don't know and i don't know oh
yeah because they were like peterborough
you know when this show takes place yeah
hogan because he stole materials you're
going to you're going to this well i'm
not 100 sure if happy is still working
with stark industries
uh if he's still there i i'm still you
know
i still think pepper is a skrull because
because of the fact that like stark
industries kind of got taken over by the
dodc i was happy to see that
uh i was confused to see why pepper
wasn't putting up a more fight about
that about losing all those materials
that is true to the government she has
her daughter yeah that is a good grade
she might not care anymore tony's gone
she's feeling out of it or she's a
scroll and she's helping out the other
skulls
in our government honestly love to hear
everyone in the chat who thinks that
everyone who in the first episode is a
scroll or who's going to be a scroll
going forward in the shields
um and go ahead again put in your super
chats or normal chats of questions and
we'll try getting them at the end for
episode one of she-hulk and hopefully i
can answer them all correctly mls beads
says if you could hulk out what would
your hook name be
um
uh horny hulk oh my gosh i'd be i'd be
chunky chippy chandler i would be so
scared of you oh god it's horrible oh no
here comes already home i bust through
the courtroom like the [ __ ] uh
sounds bad all kite in the bathroom for
30 minutes looking at my phone watching
dancing girls on tick-tock oh no
yeah
i think i'd be like cry hulk or [ __ ]
and i'd be just sad all the time
no cry i'd be caulk mls beads with
another super chat says who had the
bigger bromance tony and bruce or tony
and steve
i don't think you ever get over what
happened in civil war when you got
knocked the hell out
bucky killed his parents and steve
didn't tell him yeah and honestly i
think bruce was on it was a good move
there not to tell him my favorite part
was in uh i think this was the first
avengers uh correct me if i'm wrong but
i liked when tony uh what bruce bruce
was on tony's side about samuel jackson
nick fury being a bad person he was like
we don't know this guy or what he's
doing and he has this giant weapon and
that's right and forget that captain
america was like no i believe everything
he's gonna say
uh wait if i was red hog i could just be
the kool-aid man yeah sure yeah kind of
version but like evil i think the
kool-aid man is scary i don't think
there's a non-scary version yeah what if
he's out of his red liquid is his blood
all gone he says the pitcher no oh god
if he eats an apple do you see the apple
floating inside of the crew oh yeah
probably sangria now yeah it sounds
great oh i would love mo reese asks a
question what timeline is episode one
set here's the thing jessica goes into
that in the break group don't trust
anything that's on disney plus they get
the timeline wrong all the time yeah we
placed it after
uh after hawkeye but before
they placed it in between my name is
mary strange which is stupid because it
comes out before hawkeye
and jessica gow said it comes out
basically right after shang chi i would
say uh watch jessica's breakdown and
then maybe go outside and climb a tree
you freaking nerd who cares what
timeline it is oh my god oh my god trash
man hey i will say
there is a jump we do jump back in time
in the first episode like the coming
months right there is a little bit but
i thought that was christmas time
uh we want to check in on our
predictions from yesterday we're doing a
sort of running prediction tally
throughout the course of she-hulk we're
going to do this brother shows it's a
fantasy league it's a fantasy league um
here's the thing
a bunch of us at new rockstars are
making predictions not just the four of
us here or the three of them yesterday
we're getting a bunch of people to do it
and we're having you participate too
yesterday you guys backed jessica as
your favorite predictions so we're
giving you the points that she earned uh
and also you know next week you can
choose jessica again or choose someone
else and ride with them but can we get
the can we get the point totals on the
thing look at that
look at that brandon
squeaking ahead brandon what did he get
yeah sorry tommy uh
these are personalities can we get the
points up from the game
oh good i think this is our body count
brandon gets an extra tiny little point
he gets partial credit on uh predicting
starting soon
oh i understand what happened uh uh he
got an extra point for uh he said uh
reason for a trial was uh jennifer's
gonna be playing second fiddle lawyer
sucks not quite she wasn't the second
point second
point all right we're giving we're
giving partial credit points okay really
quick johnson can you roll a poll right
now and say whether or not bran against
i don't think i should get the point
second fiddle lawyer to someone who
sucks she almost was second fiddler
she was number one i i agree with you
i didn't i didn't say that i've got a
[ __ ]
because of you lying no no you know what
to win i want the chat to have
the chat is bad they're bad people
our viewers are awful little garbage
gremlins that eat acorns at night acorns
okay they squirrel all the acorns away
because they can't have real solid foods
that people's eats because they're trash
brandon's ahead i make the decisions
around no you don't there you go thank
you dodson so i i had said that you the
reason that you were first year in court
is because she played second fiddle to a
lair
who's worse than her she's first fiddle
she's first chance you get partial
points for that i think it's fair you're
arguing against that's crazy gonna be
mean to me for the rest of the day i
will
not fair though
i i'm the parent what did i get other
points more
first chairs is a little uh is a little
triggering for me because when i was in
band in middle school they gave me
separate sheet music that had no that
had almost no notes in it it's all rest
it's all wrestling yeah
it was obviously just me going like two
i'll run through the points i'll run
through the points scoring you got you
got points for you got points for saying
that she-hulk and hulk fight a little
bit of a cheat uh you got points for
she-hulk throws a surfboard at hulk uh i
got points for saying that the training
montage was gonna be an episode one also
a little bit of cheat and those are the
points those are the points where people
guys are oh so what are the
only drafts
the the the over under stuff is for the
whole season no but this one a glimpse
of stark industry tools you didn't get
it right uh
those aren't stark industry tools those
are home depot tools the saw blades say
stark industries on them yeah obviously
i got to do my own research on this
commercial grade saw blade right
nina's right i want my seafood boy
correction we'll have that right next
week 10 points for the chat i will take
10 points for jessica brandon gets his
point jessica's here now and yeah
chad says brandon does not get partial
points for that
you know what it doesn't matter chad
doesn't make the freaking
rolls around here he's right if we let
the chat make decisions they'd be
ramming their heads into concrete walls
i will do it for you all put them back
in the trash all right you know what
it's time to thank some sponsors thank
you
we want to shout out our friends at the
merch shop
over at epic hero shop they just
released their green justice merge line
inspired by the lady of the hour
she-hulk
it's i got several different t-shirt
designs including the newest limited
edition latest obsession shirt
lady justice
and
when you buy one of those shirts you
trigger the opportunity to
get a custom shout out read by one of
our three fantastic marvel oriented
hosts mr mastertainment
uh eric voss the man with the sauce and
jessica clemens i'd like to feed her
lemon
i can't wait what's happening yeah
[Music]
the use of triggered what made me
ah
they're also dropping lines inspired by
house of the dragon and or winnie the
pooh rings of power and uh maleficent
three so be on the lookout for those oh
and rise of group minions uh
wait what
some of those are real i don't know go
to the website
figure out what i'm lying about
rockstarsmerch.com be sure to check it
out
pick yourself up some great merch
support the channel the work we do here
it's time for regular really quickly i
want to apologize for how i reacted
about the seafood boil uh everyone in
the chat knows that i really like crab
legs and i'm sorry that i yelled at
brandon everyone in the chat i'm gonna
get you crab legs regardless baby worry
what kind of crabs are we talking about
i wouldn't describe my last legs as
crappy i can cry
no you have crampy legs
all right guys look let's let's do an
inventory here i believe dodson has
updated our finances we're at 98 bucks
not few 22 minutes left in the show
i i got i got about a gallon and a half
of green paint in my car it's going bad
it's going bad 99. all right we're
always we're ways away
ways away doctor thank you for updating
that one dollar i don't feel as hopeless
yet but
if you're feeling generous oh lemon if
you're feeling like it might be fun to
get some hulks in the show tomorrow drop
some shackles in our heckles okay oh now
it's time for mandatory fun oh no that's
right
it says tbd on that prompter dvd
wait do it again one more time
play the graphic
oh no he said he was going off script he
said he was going off yeah i'm going otd
this off the dome you want this
dumbbell
all right in a minute sit i'm scared
because we found out
yesterday
that captain america is
stroking
peggy carter
[Applause]
stroking to the west you've never heard
of that song i stuck it i just like when
you say stroking that doesn't usually
apply uh oh listen to the song stroking
by clarence carter and you will
understand he ain't talking about a
one-man band he's talking about a full
orchestra now gosh
bring in my wife
second fiddle tommy yeah uh full
orchestra
give me some trombones in the chat for
those that uh like to get weird ah
thanks guys we've got the big board out
here because for mandatory fun today
we're gonna do some detective work
and we are going to figure out who the f
f
holy shmokes thank you samuel josiah
that was very generous of you samuel oh
my gosh incredibly gentle very helpful
he wants to see us green tomorrow uh i
do think we will become green boys and
girls pretty soon i mean it was canadian
currency i like you know your dollar
your canadian dollars me a lot loonies
toonies i take them all i love still
spence their money is fun their casinos
are funner
all right well guys look at that thank
you to uh to our uh samuel josiah who is
getting us so close to being hoax we can
almost taste it now let's move out of
the way here oh i gotta go let's do some
detective work we've we tried to
replicate the board as much as possible
as our starting point yeah as our
starting points here great so yes oh god
what do we think guys walk me through
this jessica you basically have done a
breakdown of this a comprehensive uh
you're kind of the expert here right
yeah so can you can you guide us through
it yeah so this is the board that we see
in the uh mid whatever you guys want the
uh courtroom illustrations credit scenes
uh that
uh jennifer walters made for bruce as
smart hulk so we have captain america
here arrows pointing to an unknown
person we have what i said we have uh
peggy carter we have
1945 that they wrote down they wrote
down on the piece of paper which is very
are you saying are you saying he railed
a ship yeah it's gotta be wrong well
he's
goes overseas and has sex with peggy
carter
i gotta say the picture they used is a
camp lehigh photo just saying that i
know i know i know that's fine because
you can use a photo you don't have to
but this 1945 this i blame the whoever
was making the illustrations they looked
up hey when did world war two in and the
book said 1945 i'm not trying to throw
chaos here is the question mark a glory
hole
it could be it could be
this should be 1943 because basically
all the events of captain america the
first avenger basically take place in
1943 from the stark expo to him going
overseas to help get his baby bucky out
of out of jail it's it's all 1943. some
might say that's probably impossible but
it's a movie about uh a super soldier so
brandon's doing your job let me finish
really quick and so uh oh i'm sorry let
me just come in
i hear that a lot so
we have captain america pointed to the
uso girls because we're assuming it's a
uso girl but we also think that maybe
during the uso tour it was lauren
haddock's character that was playing uh
i need to move my water bottle so you
guys can see it uh autographed seeker
who also plays meredith quill's mom and
uh guardians of the galaxy two weird
names in the 1940s autograph seeker uh
yeah she wasn't she wasn't a main cast
but now she is now she's meredith quill
but again you guys this is probably not
meredith quill because meredith quill
was born in the 60s and this is 1943.
and you can go off the theories i'll
give you a grandparent maybe her mother
identical
gemma chan has played two different
characters in the mcu chris evans
uh captain marvel she's one of the
koreans yeah she's too cool so you can
be in to marshall movies michelle
uh what's in guardians
so we have two people but there is
potential that it could be someone else
yeah this is my theory yeah that is
lauren yeah lauren hannah the uso girls
that's what bruce says he says a uso
girl on the tour now this is
second-hand information well and marcus
and mcfeely the screenwriters of
avengers end game were also saying like
it was you could see you could see if
you watched captain america first
avengers there is someone in particular
that's what they said that's what they
said uh
we did we did look at the footage and
when he's doing this like first dance
the first time you hear star spangled
man with the plan this is the dance
captain here with the red hair okay yeah
if you're watching it if you're watching
the clip she's off to the left uh
captain america's right she's behind him
she's like right here during this scene
she locks eyes at the back of his head
and does not stop looking the whole time
this other one she's on this side she's
looking too she's looking too but not as
much as this one she's my main suspect
she's really locking eyes with a guy now
you can go back i made a tweet last week
where i i defended my mancap after our
very own twitter account claimed he was
a virgin and i was like no way he was on
the uso tour with that body even if he
doesn't know how to use it the girl's
gonna use him you know what i mean he's
brilliant i don't think you he he lo he
lost his virginity in 1943 and he added
a few more notches before he went to the
house my man was laying pipe like he was
a plumber but we're zeroing in on on
this is so stupid that we're doing this
but i love it we're zeroing in on the
virginity aspect yeah yeah right so
we're trying to find one person i think
little tiny steve lost his virginity oh
90 pounds well then then you're calling
bruce a liar well here's we got a couple
other candidates yeah interesting i'm
gonna i'm gonna throw this at you okay
all right in the sequence where we see
uh autographed seeker we see another
woman and she walks up the cap and she
hands something
and that's a baby okay
this woman handed caps a baby this is
your daughter could this be captain's
baby he has super sperm we don't know
how fast his sperm grows
he could have banged this woman out at a
truck stop in boise yeah and boom she
shows up at the next stop like hey i had
a baby a couple days ago that grew in in
24 hours i hate this this is yours cap
prove me wrong science prove me wrong i
got a i got a i got one i think okay i
don't know why i didn't go over whether
or not i had to do these in any specific
order no no please please i uh uh no one
was assigned any i think it was the love
of my life
natalie dormer oh okay her name's
lorraine she has a name i know her
name's lorraine but i refer to her as
natalie because
she's kind of my everything she's kind
of her everything she's just what's her
name lorraine lorraine lorraine where
was she she she's working overseas
she's working overseas in italy with the
military with tommy lee jones
uh and she kind of corners cab but they
kiss
they do kiss they do
he kisses everybody well yeah wouldn't
you kiss that baby
hey hey baby you didn't put a ring on it
he can kiss whoever he wants okay
the host of the family for you name
cheating
yes
he was in the running man ah okay
uh not on the uso tour i think bruce was
full of it but
a pivotal character in the first
avengers film okay uh i'm gonna just
replace this question mark
with
uh
mystery coffee shop girl oh yeah yeah
mystery coffee shop girl played by
ashley johnson ashley of the blacklist
um what was he also in spiderman she's
also critical role i have no idea i have
no idea what she was in she was in the
blacklist um she here's the thing
there was a deleted scene with her where
they were
supposed to go on a date with her she
gives an interview at the end that was
like oh my god captain america saved me
you don't think he was rolling up to
that coffee shop after that he saved the
entire world and was like hey how about
that date and then you know one thing
leads to another
uh ashley johnson i think if he did if
he did go into the isa virgin and gets
thought out and he's like oh and then he
finds out i'm in new york it's not 1943
anymore he runs outside this is the
first girl he meets he's like i've been
in ice for a long time i need to be not
be able to immediately i've been bricked
up in ice yeah yeah
for for 60 years the bluest yeah yeah
very cool they thought me out dick first
okay
let me throw out a wild card here okay
dumb dumb duggan oh i didn't print out
dumb dumb duggan but i did ask come come
come come snug him all right
as soon as you said it i said rum tom
tugger
we will be breaking down cats we will be
doing epic hero merchandise for cats
buttholes intact put the buttholes back
on the kids like please don't tell them
that we're gonna have to do it i'll do
whatever i want
you guys can do as much as you i will
actively be there for you guys doing
cats okay um no i love cats it's my
favorite musical either way okay sorry
uh
i am gonna give what everybody in the
chat wants because in the military if i
was there for a long time with my homie
i'd probably hook up
oh my god wow james
james you're getting away look how cute
you're more comfortable uh experimenting
with your best friend yeah the end
to the other line just pre-stonewall but
two boys from new york you know i i
until the end of the line here's no i
don't think this is who cap lost his
virginity to
by any means but it's someone we need to
respect who's definitely
seeing the other side of the shield if
you know what i mean
we have evidence
we have evidence of it ooh a kiss oh my
gosh
it's the black widow they definitely
fooled around yeah they definitely were
like she wasn't his first but she was
maybe as loud as she was dan stuff first
they were there they go over they go
over to sam wilson's apartment they're
like hey we need to use your shower
bang i got camera set up boom let's go
there is also the man who got
the star-spangled man a plan this lovely
like senator stop it stop i was like
very much like
what a dime piece you are you printed
him out but
peggy carter's niece
sharon carter yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's known she's a scroll there's
nothing there but we need to do the
family tree of who he's
in her family
peggy carter sharon carter
coach carter
uh
they changed their name when they came
over all right here's what i want here's
what i want dotson
uh red alert here we go i want to pull
who did cap lose his virginity to lose
his virginity too that is the question
right are we going peggy carter yeah are
we going meredith quill aka uh what was
our autograph girl autograph are we
going bucky barnes
are we going come on you gotta get my
girl in there please just uh dormer's
character what's up lorraine
there's four
he claimed he claimed he was a uso girl
but i think i think you're right that
that's a cover i think it's kind of lied
to bruce i think while we're waiting for
that poll i want to talk to you guys
about something else that happens in
that scene okay i want to talk to you
about oh by the way uh jessica goes into
details about how this actually works in
the breakdown so she might have actually
please found a definitive answer um
that seems really interesting right
because jen walters is like she's she's
a little drunk she goes i can't believe
he died a virgin now we didn't know cap
was dead all right
he was on the moon we thought he was
maybe just an old man somewhere and then
bruce says something that's also
interesting he says he's not a virgin
present tense so here's the question
right
i mean i guess we can't find a
definitive answer for this but like is
cap dead yes or no
brandon uh cap's not dead nobody no no
death
i think that the general public is under
the assumption that he's dead okay and
that's why she says it like that
and bruce is like he's too busy getting
his story straight that it slips out and
he's not gonna say that he's dead sure
but i would also see bruce being in the
head space where even if cap is dead not
saying he's dead because he doesn't want
to accept that reality but even saying
like he didn't die a virgin that would
be like the default thing you would yeah
yeah to that yes um
uh dead yes or no he's dead to me oh boy
and he knows why i should clarify steve
rogers not steve rogers america alive
okay
he's got to be a liar they're saving it
for something i think he's dead
why why would they not just say it then
because i don't think they want to like
they want to have the i want you to have
the option i think like i think
generally they're like he he's
effectively dead he's 100 years old or
116 or whatever we did on an episode a
big question i think they want to like
they don't want to do a funeral they
didn't give nad a funeral whatever uh
they just want to sort of say you don't
think they're pulling like a late night
show scenario where
uh it's like jay leno and conan o'brien
where they're telling sam wilson like
yeah you're the new captain in america
don't worry don't worry and then a few
months into it they're gonna be like hey
it's general america now and then steve
rogers comes back and sam wilson has to
be like come on this is my gig like what
are you talking about you're like no
it's a different thing he's general
america
and then poor captain america goes on
tbs yeah yeah and then they make captain
america
secondly he's on the next day
yeah uh i think he's i think he's dead i
think he's dead here's what the chat had
to say about uh this this virginity they
said 43 is an autograph
autograph girl autographed girl i'm not
gonna say what happens in the breakdown
um but you know why was pay we shouldn't
have done peggy he didn't lose it to
peggy we don't know cape lehigh was so
you think he just loses
alive so yes or no if i was steve rogers
this is what i would do
uh well what if they did hook up in the
backseat of that car we just didn't
really see real quick
before he changed does that count if you
pull around he jumped on a grenade he
jumped out on a grenade in camp lehigh
peggy was standing right there you just
saved my life even though it didn't go
off
you you think that they're not yeah but
you don't need to remember
so would you say
that's like it would be like being with
a small child she's like i can't do that
so are you
saying he prefers a the backseat windows
up that's the way he likes to
we all seemed tight i like you you
edited yourself there yeah at no other
point during the come come duggar rank
didn't you bother
yourself do you want to go to super chat
yeah let's get some super chats while
this poll comes in um go ahead grandma
j.s gsu ego 117 saying come for the kang
gang stay for the kang bang jesus what
have you done what was happening
i just let them crawl out from under the
rocks they already lived in uh mls
speeds asking do you think steve told
peggy if he had a kid
oh so she has a kid
uh he he hits it right before he goes in
the eyes she has a kid
sends it out for adoption because she
can't better look at it and then steve
comes back and she's like oh i i gotta
bring that up
that kid's that kid's old as hell yeah i
know thank you to christian suzeen tony
tyler slayer army hannah basto all
sending in super chats justin gillips uh
justin gillespie asking him
i i hit it again for justin uh hit him
against the graphic for j-man uh
this is me
this is me sending a chat saying just
you are queen check john's math it's
wacky i don't know that refers too much
samuel josiah asking if this helps ah it
certainly did yeah that was uh
incredible it should also be noted while
we're going through the super chats
thank you so much uh we are hulking out
tomorrow
away from me
uh going green from my
uh my yapper to my clapper and we will
we will show the receipts
of that clap
clapper mls beats did clarify about
bruce and tony's uh heavy relationships
the reason i asked is that when tony is
helping bruce he drink some moments
about steve sounds like a broken heart
oh that mean he does have a little
broken heart i guess that's true um
uh gsu eagle asking is it possible that
doom could have anything to do with
titanium's powers he's behind it all we
can still get behind titanic
uh honestly honestly i think we could
still get it but if they want to lean
anything now that we got we gave it to
miss marvel the same thing we're
probably going to give it to titania
yeah and so they're going to stress yeah
here's my pitch she's not powered
those were set charges to go off because
it was a point it's a
mysterious they set up charges in the
courtroom to blow up and that's why
well she was pretty easily great
kylie davis saying the grand master
coming back for hulk quote let me just
scoop up this golden daggers club real
quick
uh a graveyard with the depraved gourd
saying i may have a depraved heart but
the break room cast and crew make the
last hour of work fun keep it up
i hope you're not like an airline pilot
because that last hour is the most
important you gotta land the plane buddy
we're going down to the hudson it's
sully sullivan
thank you for that comment
i do look like dr sloan uh ashton adams
asking whose constipations are worse
eddie brock or bruce
this first oh okay so i here's what i
will say mr poop man well give your
answers because i have the real answer
for this okay eddie brock or who or
bruce banner eddie brock dude eddie
brock's got him cause remember how venom
is eating all those chickens yeah
but who do you think's got worse
constipation isn't hulk like eating a
guy's head
no that that that's always eddie brock
that's always yeah i don't know heads
are tough to digest traditionally well
here's here's the boring answer folks uh
the venom symbiote when it it's over a
person and it's during the eating the
symbiote is doing the eating and absorbs
everything before it comes into the the
the host that's holding it so the food
never makes it into the things bodies
though uh it has been said in the comics
and in the movie that they can taste it
because when eddie brock in the first
venom movie after we don't see the
uh the robber at the convenience store
get his head bit off we hear it we don't
see it because it was jesus
uh eddie brock kind of gets up and makes
like a tasting thing so he definitely
tastes stuff but it doesn't go into
their digestive system what if it's just
a texture well franklin richards uh
pointed out in the comics too
it wasn't eddie brock but to one of the
hosts of the venom that venom's green
slime is like slime that he puts on
people when he licks people and
everything that's venom's poop
everything he eats gets secreted out via
via that goopy
so that's the poop so unfortunately
doesn't make it into the stomachs it
goes out uh and then i don't think
bruce's constipation is that bad because
hulk just would heal it up so fast
here's something from mls beads that
says if glk and h planted titania
wouldn't they have also made themselves
lose the case
uh
uh who's going to pick up the group of
lawyers who didn't save the jury they're
going to throw the case out it's a
mystery yeah the case got thrown out
they were already going to lose my guess
they were going to lose they did this
stunt and they're going to throw it yeah
it's like they're willing to sacrifice
one case to get off yeah take it off
guys 424 more dollars in the super chat
and i'll baptize the baby
you got one nancy in the chat and nick
morris saying the ship is delivering
scar to earth that's something that uh
jessica was really talking about
yesterday
uh samuel
laura haddock's character in captain
america could have been peter quill's
great grandma and cap could be his great
grandfather please everybody
family why's it got to be famous
what did we learn from the targaryens
keep it in the family listen if they
looked at the targaryens i'd keep it in
the family
tony kevin letting everyone know he's
young
don't blame him for the trash and stuff
tony put him on a mug that is adorable
that's cute uh that is i like that i
like that we've got a couple of other
regular chat questions because we're
feeling generous today frey girl says i
think the scene where bruce quote fries
her blood is gonna be important could be
that he didn't really fry the blood so
he can experiment on it i do think like
it was a brain they talked about her
blood a lot yeah yeah well i mean he
pointed out like the blood is very
dangerous yeah and this was shown on the
show just a little bit of blessing stop
writing
in the chat
750 and we turn tommy into music
tomorrow
i've been sitting here just shaking and
reading it i mean we did we did point it
out eyeballs 120. what if yeah
i mean what if cap smash bucky yeah i
say if you're two consenting adults and
you want to do it do it
don't let it don't let society get in
the way you know every one of you
writing it in the chat is my enemy
you're just sitting there there i'm
gonna make a list
i'm gonna check it twice uh dan schrock
saying nicky may be a squirrel she's
definitely a squad trust for sure
[Laughter]
uh well as you fill our chat with two
musicians we want to fill your hearts
with love yes uh we hope you've had a
great day here on the break we've had a
lot of fun we're so excited that
she-hulk is here and we have a new show
to chat about remember there's going to
be those mid-credits scenes every
episode you people love it you want to
get it hey
so i just want to say
i've had a lot of fun today we didn't
get to the goal of the full hulk body
paint thing but close enough i'll
probably do something fun anyway maybe
get some green paint from my whistler to
my pistol you know
uh remember
that you just had that one locked
out uh
yeah make sure you check out our discord
if you're 18 years or older hop on there
you can submit a clip of the week
there's probably no good clips from
today but check out the other episodes
this week pull a good clip and submit it
it was a joke
jeez you know what's going to be really
fun is when my mom's like what does
thomassie mean
i really like my mom watches every
episode my mom's retired she's not
watched a single one of these things
also uh you can follow the break room on
tic tac that's right we're at the
underscore break room tommy's gonna put
some new ticks on those tanks right
that's right look at zach in the chat
he's going to get a job don't don't
worry about it
oh my god
[Applause]
if you're still watching the video
please hit that like button uh we pinned
that comment and
have a great rest of your thursday we'll
see you tomorrow we're going to be
helped out uh and please at home keep it
goofy
we'll see you guys tomorrow